it is what it is i am what i am you get
what you get
that's why i said somebody [ __ ] up
when they gave me 150 000 subscribers
susan would just be gonna find out that
won't be fine tomorrow
oh who did it i had to say i had the
same thought when my other channel got
remonetized recently and i was like oh
dude
somebody's getting fired i feel bad like
you know
you know like it's poor [ __ ] gonna be
having to sit in an office and go
i didn't know i i didn't know i just i
saw videos he was
i don't know playing music he was
playing video games he was reading chat
comments he seemed pretty normal
i didn't realize he was who you say he
is have have you
are you are you worried about getting
kicked off of youtube because i mean the
stuff you say i mean i gotta be honest
and iris that's why we like it you
respect it it's
it's wild like you said you said yeah
sometimes people will go play the new
barricade garage and i'm like i gotta
watch it first i just yeah
i got a you know i want to tow a line
here
i don't want to lose with superman i get
it i i get it but i mean
that's why i still work i'm a working
man i'm a
i'm a working man i work for a living i
work with my hands that's what i
do um this was always just a side hustle
a hobby i never really put too much
emotion behind it until
i started getting big then the [ __ ]
[ __ ] check started coming in a lot of
people like talking about their youtube
checks
because these shits look good when you
first start getting them and you kind of
want to
get in line you kind of want to get
mainstream
when you start making like [ __ ] 15 20
000 a month
doing some [ __ ] but i mean not all money
is good money i got
i i got morals this year like i'm not
just about to sit here
like that ryan long [ __ ] i could have
been
i could have been a hardcore
conservative
i could have did [ __ ] that i didn't even
believe in
just to do this [ __ ] make a video put a
video out on it
and make money right now it's a lot of
content with joe biden in
office i could be talking about this
[ __ ] all that damn they
kill a gang but i'd rather talk about
other stuff
like who's running [ __ ] i don't want to
talk about the puppets i want to talk
about the puppet masters
and i feel like that's what sets me
apart from the rest
i mean look man i i agree it's it's true
because
we've i catch myself you become
conditioned right
and sometimes you go wow this
conditioning is working it works on me
and i really try my best not to wear
things that 10 years ago that if
somebody would have said i'd be like oh
that's [ __ ] hilarious now you're like
oh i can't believe they said that i'm
like wait why am i acting this way
what what happened in 10 years for
example that that reprogrammed my mind
to find this
offensive because this just used to be
funny we used to just [ __ ] joke
around and nobody cared
but now you're like oh i can't believe
he said that and everyone's cove
grasping at you know their pearls and
stuff and
i it it it's it's crazy but like you
know you say the people in charge but it
works man
even when you try for it not to work if
you get beat over the head enough enough
enough i have to catch myself going like
why am i being a
what am i doing why do i don't why am i
covering my mouth and gasping who gives
a [ __ ]
um that's true that's why that's why oh
i don't hate nobody neither i'm not i'm
not beating on
i'm not calling out nobody i don't got
beef with nobody
i don't i don't do that that's that
[ __ ] they sons to me i don't do that
[ __ ] but
shout out to f ryan long awakening with
jp everybody else who everybody else
finds funny i'm not
in it to be found funny it's like a i
said you don't got to follow me don't
follow me like don't
don't put yourself in a position to
where you have to backpedal on something
that i might say later because i'm not
gonna tow any particular party line
so that's why i can see why a lot of
people wouldn't want to have me on the
show
i had me do an interview because i may
might say something about you
but i had a subscriber a lot of them
when our first day was like yo go on
brandon tatum show
only eat a cop i'm going brandon tatum
show
you're not gonna want me on that
[ __ ] because you know we don't
we don't you know so
yeah so we're not gonna see like a heel
turn in a year you're not gonna be like
wearing a suit on tim pool's show being
like
look i'm all for free speech but it does
have consequences
[Laughter]
look i agree you know they're just
sitting there all just like talking like
you know
talking about selling food buckets
coming up next on tim pool we have
barricade garage steam he's coming up to
tell us about this by the way real [ __ ]
tim poole like when the when the covet
[ __ ] first started right like we were
one of the only shows
that we were catching a lot of [ __ ] from
people for going like
look i understand if you want to take
precautions for your health
i understand that but like you can't
lock down a whole country for a virus
this is unprecedented we can't do this
and everybody called us irresponsible
and dangerous timple had the same exact
take at first he was like we can't do
that this
we have civil liberties we have a
constitution you can't just lock people
down for a virus
then he got a we we both us
and tim poole got approached at the same
time by my patriot food supply
and you remember the meeting you had the
guy the guy goes oh this covet thing
it's red hot we
we can't even keep stock of all these
food buckets they're flying off the
shelves just use the covet angle
and we were like yeah we'll get back to
you and then we just never signed
a week later tim poole's like look the
trump is signing executive orders we're
going to have martial law
this virus is going to kill 30 billion
people and you look
my patriots supply right now they
haven't it's like i was going
oh my god like within a week he just
was like full-blown food bucket prepper
guy and i'm like
tim a week ago you were you had a way
more nuanced approach like we did
it changes people but it but it's like
he was saying like
you you get that check you get that
money coming in every month
you you start you start going like oh
this is great oh so
so see i think when a lot of people you
know sacrifice their principles and
sacrifice their morals
it doesn't happen in one like this like
it's not like night and day it's not a
180 it's little by little right
it's like okay so i just won't mention
this okay so i just don't mention that
and then a year you know two years down
the road you're a completely different
person
right like a lot of people see that
money and it gets good and then they
provide a market the people provide a
market
for counter culture to come somebody to
counter what the media is saying
and people need to fill that void so
they step up and they see the money is
good
and they keep doing it even though you
know that's not something they
necessarily believe in or that may not
be the direction they want to take their
show
or channel they'll do it because the
check is good and before you know it now
you have this
conservative figure who's not really a
conservative that rebranded himself
with conservative values even though
that's not really him
because the money's good now he has a
conservative following
and he really can't turn around now so
we just gotta keep going forward
and i guess that's how you say get you
get a lot of grifters and [ __ ] like that
man
yeah it happens yeah you know and so
what happens
also is like the you know it's youtube
man youtube used to be
wild back in the day right you used to
come on youtube and you can [ __ ]
alex jones screaming about you know
they're taking over the country
and stuff like that and now you come on
youtube and it's just curated and like
it's an nbc report or it's fouchy
talking about something it's like
man to find anything even worth a [ __ ]
you gotta dig and the problem is you
know you don't get these
you're not gonna get any free thinking
big channels anymore you know because
once you get to a certain point and you
want that that's the downside with like
youtube or any of these things
once you get on the radar once you're on
the radar they go okay we gotta stop
this and then you get shadow band
and then they don't push you anymore and
they kick you out of the algorithm
and i don't know mike wha what's you
know i know you said this
you know you're a working man you you
got you got you know if this goes away
tomorrow
you're going to be fine but a lot of
people put all their eggs in one basket
and they're going to find themselves
without anything
you know w with it to me it's not even
about the money to me it's about
man there's no more you can't talk about
anything you can't joke about anything
there's no more ideas you can get out
there anymore you can't even
you know and i'm not one of those like
oh you know but facts don't care about
your feelings facts like i don't care
about that [ __ ] but what i'm talking
about is like
just [ __ ] talking about anything
joking about anything you're not allowed
to do that [ __ ] anymore well i guess
they make you believe you're not allowed
to but i mean it's one of those things
where it's like
well it's not against the constitution
you're allowed to see what you want but
then you can't take out a bank loan or
have a credit card you know
or they pull your merchant services
because you're on the match list
yeah that was the other thing right they
they now have
banks uh this happened to a friend of
ours uh dick masterson he had like a
patreon alternative
and mastercard just put them on this
thing called the match list which was
part of operation chokepoint which was
part of the patriot act which was a way
to
cut off funding to islamic terrorists
but of course it's a loophole that's
gotten abused
so they basically just like he just one
day got an email and the bank was like
we can't process credit cards for you
anymore we can't do merchant services
for you
you're on this match list and he's like
okay and then he did his research and
then he went and found some shady like
chinese credit union in l.a like there
was like some small family-owned chinese
credit union
and at first they're like okay yeah wait
we take it it's fine and uh but then
like after about three or four weeks
the chinese credit union was like look i
don't know what the [ __ ] you did to
mastercard bro but
we can't process correct we're not going
to lose matt if we have to choose
between
dick masterson or mastercard sorry buddy
you're gone and that's some [ __ ] they
really do and
dick dick's not exactly uh i wouldn't
exactly call him a goose
stepping white supremacist he's a comedy
guy he's like
ozzy does comedy stuff but he it that's
it man they put you on a list bro and
you're [ __ ]
not forget youtube not paying you we're
talking [ __ ]
banks telling you we can't let you open
an account here that's scary [ __ ]
yeah it's actually people that die
behind telling the truth sometimes the
last thing you worried about is being
cancelled
but you you just to be focused sometimes
if you focus and you hone in on your
craft the audience you build over here
they'll follow you anywhere so
now you got a small following sometimes
when you ban people it just makes them
bigger i mean we witnessed this
with gangs with larry hoover and the
gangster disciples in chicago
sometimes when you take people out
you need it's like regime chain change
almost it's like when you take people
out sometimes they'll put somebody else
in that spot but
i mean if you don't have nobody to fill
that void then [ __ ] gonna fall into
chaos
and and the very thing he was trying to
censor it's only gonna get bigger
somewhere else
that's why i said the best way to meet
unpopular ideas
is head on and let the culture figure
out hey
we don't want these people saying this
but we don't want these people saying
that same thing with mass
they didn't make you wear a mask they
didn't force you to wear masks they
ain't put a gun in your head and say oh
you got wedded [ __ ] you got shamed and
that's what we used to do back in the
day
to get people to act right he used to
shame you if you had a little son little
boy walking around
thought he was a girl hands on his
hippie [ __ ] you like cut that [ __ ] out
what the [ __ ] are you doing you get mad
at your dad hey
the [ __ ] is that what the [ __ ] is going
on that's like the dwayne wade that
that's why
that's why the dwyane wade thing man the
dwayne wayne thing to me is hilarious
because you know dwyane wade
he didn't play any of that [ __ ] man
we're coming and then all of a sudden
now he has a trans kid and it's like
hey don't talk about my daughter that
way that's that's why i love a little
boosie little voucy's my don't cut his
dick off man
come on he a little boy man let don't be
gay
like the whole video and he's red eyes
he's so [ __ ] up in the video it's like
three in the morning and he's going
come on man don't cut the boy dick off
man
what a lot what a lot of us was thinking
we just didn't have the balls to say not
weak but we didn't have the balls to say
we know that's some [ __ ]
we know you don't do that [ __ ] to a
child you're supposed to raise them up
in the way they go
teach them yeah because what what's
barry weiss going to do to lil boosie
you know what i mean like it's not like
barry weiss or lindy west is going to
write a blog about lil boosie and all of
a sudden everybody's going to turn on
him yeah you know
he's the perfect guy to say it you know
who else is not going to have balls
dwyane wade's kid if he keeps going this
way
it's not and that that's just [ __ ]
sad but the parents
they love that [ __ ] because they get the
attention for it and the culture has
shifted
over there out in hollywood it's such
that when you do [ __ ] like that
you get recognition and hand claps from
your
hollywood peers hey oh yeah he's a
[ __ ]
just like that other [ __ ] with the big
name uh january jones
uh angelina jolie charlie charlie
the son that she adopted from africa got
him walking around got there
looking all stupid and [ __ ] like yo is
she getting handcuffs from angelina
jolie she getting all types of accolades
and [ __ ]
so now it makes you feel good now you
want to [ __ ] up more kids
now you're doing this [ __ ] pushing this
agenda on the kids
to satisfy your [ __ ] up self
and people will do it because they get
praised for doing it if you didn't get
praised for doing it
a lot of these people wouldn't be doing
this i'm still convinced that dwyane
wade's kid thing is just
uh it's like a secret plot to get the uh
wnba
ratings up oh yeah it's a good point i
figure you'll go play there
and people will finally want to watch
that horse [ __ ]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
merch and i were at a bar and they had
like the female final four on because i
don't know they wanted us to kill
ourselves
and we were watching it and it was like
[ __ ] halftime when the score was like
10 to 23 and i'm like holy [ __ ] why the
[ __ ] did they even allow this
the score's up yeah uh sorry so
let's ask what do you what do you watch
like what
what besides anime because i already i
already heard your dragon ball reference
what do you watch on tv do you watch
anything or
are you have you tapped out from all of
it no i
tapped out from all of it like right now
i just took like
a week off from like anything mainstream
media
usually what i'll do is to try to find
material is i'll go look at the news
see who the [ __ ] to make fun of then i
felt like um
so i just cut myself off and i
um you feel freer you feel better but
it's like damn it's like what do i talk
about and that's another thing about
comedians if all you can talk about
is woke [ __ ] or making fun of woke [ __ ]
it's like yeah if the walk [ __ ] goes
away who
are you so i used to make skits on like
little stupid [ __ ] on my king vader
caleb city
long beach griffey [ __ ] like that's the
type of [ __ ] i like i don't like all
that political [ __ ]
because then she gets monotonous it gets
boring
and it's [ __ ] downright depressing
like i watched
an awakening with jp video i'll be i'll
watch people i'm all over these youtube
streams
i watch his last video he just repeated
verbatim in that guidance counselor
style voice
it's almost like linguist it's almost
like neuro linguistic programming or
some [ __ ] it's like
it's like my [ __ ] guidance counselor
used to call me to the office and she
just sit there and talk to me in this
kind of voice and talk to me like this
really not be saying [ __ ] just parody
what the [ __ ]
leftist media is saying and and then
people are like oh
that's so [ __ ] funny [ __ ] it's my
ass [ __ ] depression though like you
know
but um i mean and i really don't watch
anime i just grew up watching dragon
ball z because i used to beat people up
and [ __ ]
and i remember when i was seven i used
to try to power up like goku and [ __ ]
probably with vegeta and [ __ ] and i used
to go to school and thought i was goku
and [ __ ] but
man like that's why i bring up driving i
really don't watch that anime [ __ ] like
that for real so
people be asking me questions i really
don't know i don't want to see fake or
nothing i don't really watch this
it's funny you brought up because we
mentioned on this show too it's like
uh the the people that they're they're
in the last four years there's
people that have made that have become
their entire career
is based on making fun of trump right
like for example it's like
that's all they they mike points aside
and mike pointed this out to me i
thought it was amazing
pointed it out to me it's like there's
verified people on twitter that their
entire life
was being the number one comment under
one of trump's tweets yeah that was
right
now he's gone so you're just staring
into the void now
and then so what you're finding is it's
like you don't you
once you take away somebody's super
villain
they don't have they don't have anything
anymore it's like
you've taken it away from them so now
okay
let's go see you go be funny now without
trump what do you got and they can't
because that's all they have that's what
happened like sarah silverman i know if
you saw what sarah silverman did like
sarah silverman for four years was just
making fun of trump make fun of trump
and like a couple weeks ago she made a
video saying like
you know i'm really tired of both
political sides you know
you know my own side's holding me down
it's like yeah now it is
not because you don't have evil orange
man to make fun of and i agree with you
because there's a lot of people
that make their entire thing about oh
look how terrible sjws are and woke is
crowder for example and when you take
that out of it it's like can you
go look go look at dave ruben stand up
before he became a political commentator
it's one of the worst things you like
dave rubin yeah yeah
yeah there's uh there's a video he did
uh from like
10 to 15 years ago when co got comment
when comics was still open yeah it's
hard to tell
he did some like gay themed
stand-up show it was all gay right it
was it was gay comics
in town and it was like he was hosting
and it's i mean the entire
everything he said was like any gay
people here
i'm gay anyone gay yeah but it bothers
you that i'm gay and it's like the whole
crowd's gay everyone on the bill is gay
is all you have is gay material because
like i just think it's weird like if
you're gonna go
in front of a crowd that's going to be
very homogeneous
the last thing i would want to do is
just like
material about that group it's like
you just spent all week being these
people am i going to just talk about
like you know what i mean if i had a
white conservative crowd then i go do
comedy i'm not going to just start doing
a bunch of like how cool is trump jokes
because it's like
you guys have all been hanging out and
sucking each other you know sucking
trump's dick in facebook groups all week
why would you want to pay a two-drink
minimum and come in here and hear me
listen to me suck trump's dick so it's
like i would try to mix it up a little
bit but yeah everything he did was like
gay
okay am i right man it's crazy being gay
and everybody's like okay i guess
and and now what he does is like i'm gay
and conservative i bet that bothers you
liberals i'm like
no what bothers me is that you're not
talented i don't care what dicks you put
in your mouth
what bothers me about dave rubin is he
very clearly has
one of those have you ever seen the
things they advertised in the
information
that you taped to the front of your head
and then you comb it over and you fill
in the front of the yeah
dave rubin i will i put all the ca i
have i think i have like 230 bucks in
cash on me right now put it all up right
now
on david the [ __ ] toupee yeah but not
a full toupee they had these things on
the infomercials where it just went
along the clues on the front of your
head
stripper your head and it adds to your
hair and then you comb it over
i remember seeing those on tv and being
like these are ridiculous but dave rubin
was bald and i know he has this perfect
i don't know man it's like stitching or
something you have exactly 230 dollars
on you which means i know you're gonna
buy weed
if you have that much cash i don't know
that amount of money is i'm going to buy
an ounce of weed money yeah i paid my
rent yesterday i'm going because
all right you know you don't have to um
come on man
by the way the show might be late later
tonight i'm just like why on a
completely unrelated it's not cuz you're
gonna go
we might be starting at 10 30 tonight
but uh that's the other thing about
conservatives too that i ain't get
around to talking about
they'll often have when the liberals get
so aggressive the left is so aggressive
the right has a need to counter punch
that
so what i seen happen when trump got in
office
was a lot of black conservatives just
started popping up out of nowhere
and what the conservative party did what
the republicans did
was prop up a lot of black conservatives
to be like oh look
well y'all saying this about us look we
got this
and then put him on and and go get we
got this
we got keisha too ain't no [ __ ] name
we got keisha too
it's like they they prop up people to
counter
what the left has to say about them so
every
i feel like that's that party is
reactionary
well dude it's like it's like that
minstrel show diamond and silk
where i'm like what are you doing guys
come on do you know the whole story
behind candace owens
like her whole origin story no i
i mean just the basics she was a leftist
she ran it yeah she ran a doc
she wanted to start a doxing website a
few years ago
she wanted to team up with the girl from
gamergate
to start a website where all of your
online stuff that was anonymous would be
logged cataloged and then they put your
real name and they would have these
profiles on this website
where they could track all the [ __ ]
you're doing online and connect it to
all your anonymous accounts
uh social autopsy it was social autopsy
and it was a total
website where she wanted to just dox
people for saying mean words on the
internet
and then she started making turning
point usa money
and she's like hey man free speech and
you're like wait what
you wanted to run a website where i have
people's name you wanted to basically
run like a a
internet schindlers list you know what i
mean like
what the [ __ ] now you're a conservative
okay i guess whatever
people go where the money goes man yeah
they go where the money goes she went
from pray to you
to [ __ ]
shapiro working with shapiro and [ __ ]
like
god man shapiro shapiro is one of them
that you know
he he probably is up there with one of
them that bothers me
the most in terms of how he sways like
you know he's supposed to be a
libertarian but we played a video of him
the other day where he's like
okay folks but force faction nations are
great first vaccinations are amazing
and everybody should get them because
i'm a libertarian but i'm going to do
mental gymnasts
gymnastics to tell you why it's almost
like he's getting orders
you know almost
they go to the secret bilderberg
meetings and get their orders
yeah you definitely have orders you
definitely have to fall in line you
can't be an individual to the point
where
it hurts the person that's sponsoring
you paying for [ __ ]
or the person that gave you their
platform and then you develop a sense of
loyalty
to that sad person or entity now you
have to act like this
when you used to act like that and
people see the difference but
you know when you start making money
like that you don't care
no that's a good point look yeah you're
right once you're buying a beach house
you know what i mean you're buying a
beach house and you have a nice car and
you're in that you're in that nice tax
bracket where
you get that high tax bracket where you
don't pay taxes anymore because you have
all the write-offs
why why why even have any morals why
even have anything like you know
the shippers is a great example it's a
45-minute show and it has like seven ads
in it i mean i've heard them do ads for
things where it's like
okay folks let's talk about food buckets
i can't eat it because
because you know i'm a jew and it's it's
not kosher but you know the rest of you
people should eat it and when you hear
stuff like that you're like
man this guy doesn't hold true to
anything yeah shapiro's doing [ __ ]
live reads for
shellfish [ __ ] alcohol
wait a minute what is going on here uh
this is ben shapiro for the bds movement
folks let me tell you something you're
going
wait what it's like i'll take money from
anybody i don't care
oh man but you know man we honestly got
to tell you we look i don't remember
what the first video was that we found
we found out yours but i mean it was
when we saw we're like man you're you
know and then we we're like oh he's
funny and then when you
you got wild with some of them that's
our general reactions when we saw them
we were like
jesus christ man and we're like honestly
in a way like you said like
there is a form and i'll be honest if
you're like jealous you're like man we
can't we can't get away with saying that
we get kicked off of this platform and a
heartbeat but it's
refreshing to be able to see somebody
actually saying it and some people
actually
you know listening to what the real
problem is instead of like
this divide and conquer you know they
want everybody at their throats right
because if everyone's fighting with each
other no one's looking up and going like
wait a second who's that guy up there
that's laughing at all this you know
i will say nothing shocks me but you
have definitely said some things and
phrased some things
in a way where i've lit you know we do
that move where you look behind you
yeah you know when you're alone in a
room and you're watching a video he said
some [ __ ] where i'm like
oh [ __ ] okay yeah
okay i gotta get up walk around the room
please
what i say is basic as hell
that's what people used to be able to
like i'm not saying nothing
outlandish it's just that's how soft
core
in kindergarten everything is gotten
like i'm not really saying that that's
too wild out there it's just that's how
kindergarten everything has gotten
it's it's it's here you're right and i
mean i don't know man like
what what are you what do you what can
we do outside of just being
telling people to be themselves and
being you know morally strong like what
what can you do because like for some
people it's it's easy to be like man be
yourself say whatever you want but like
mike brought up earlier it's like
man if you got a family and stuff and
you have kids and they tell you hey you
can't have a credit card or get a loan
anymore it's like
how can you how are you allowed to even
be yourself anymore if they're going to
take your livelihood away you know
see that's that's the thing about it and
when people give
give a scenario like that it's hard to
actually believe
people in the past was faced with that
same
opportunity decision they had to make on
the well-being of her family
and some people chose
death some people said slavery is a
choice
and they chose death the more people
that die
for your cause is sometimes
the only way to win i mean i know that
sounds crazy
but i'll go back to 300 i know we
talking about like freedom of speech and
[ __ ] but
it still applies i'll take it back to
300. king leonidas
he took an army of 300 people
he knew he was going to lead him to the
slaughter but he needed to provoke
the the spartan government not the
government but the council so allowed
him
to release the full spartan army so he
took them
knowing he would die because once you
kill the king
it's automatic war so i can release the
full
so he can release the full um spartan
army on the persians
and we can crush it so he sacrificed
himself
some people when it comes to freedom
they can't fathom anything being
more valuable than their life right
but if freedom is then your life
is one small sacrifice to pay
for your kids and your countrymen to be
able to have that freedom you see what
i'm saying
it's the same thing with freedom of
speech and this is why
i lose hope in humanity every day
because a lot of people have jobs
a lot of people have to make money
to support feed and clothe their family
it's a lot of men out here
they have to work they got to support
the woman
they need they got a car that needs
fixing
so they won't do anything too aggressive
they'll act like it but they won't do
anything too aggressive towards
the beast system that's imposing these
restrictions on their life
they'll say it but they won't do
anything
in order to actually get somewhere
sometimes
you have to do something the more people
that do something
the less the [ __ ] [ __ ] occurs like these
people are human if people call them
elite
call them a machine these people are
still human
they bleed like you bleed put their
pants on like you put
put your pants on they got corporations
who gives a [ __ ] they in it for money
but enough people was like nah
done with this [ __ ] they gonna switch up
culture can change overnight
we've seen that happen the thing is a
lot of people
don't value freedom over their life
and that's america's downfall forgot who
you were
yeah we've we've we've beco we've become
too comfortable um
i mean when it really is kind of like
that
when when the when when we're the only
country that has poor fat people you get
to the point where you're like
i i we we have it so easy where it's
it's it's and look
i'll admit man it it's tough to give up
dude cushy lifestyle right like
it's it's tough to to be like uh do i
really want to actually put yourself out
there i mean
you know like i said you know during the
revolution like we started a war over
like a two percent tax increase
we burned it down we sent kids to die
over
much less than what they're doing to us
now you know much less
uh and and at the end it's like you know
how how much are you willing to
sacrifice and i think
well we all become a little bit guilty
of being like ah you know
do i really want to go do this do i
really want to go defend what i believe
or do i just want to be comfortable
and at the end man it trickles down and
down and then you know 20 years from now
we're all going to be
i don't know man i mean we're kind of
already slaves right i mean you know to
what we could say or what we could do
and and um
i don't know i don't know where it's
gonna end look man we're coming up
towards the end of the show but
we gotta have a part two this was great
i mean we i had a
yeah man thanks for finally coming on
man i uh like i said it was
going back to like when he left that
comment on my page one day and i was
just like oh [ __ ] i'm like this guy
rules like i was actually excited so
i'm glad we managed to work this out
it's barricade garage on youtube
uh everyone subscribe i mean he does he
does [ __ ] hilarious
videos above all else you're [ __ ]
hilarious our channel's like
a third like a tenth i know right we're
like yeah we're gonna give him the old
uh
man thanks for being on man thanks for
slamming it with us man man i appreciate
y'all man shout out to y'all both of
y'all y'all keep doing what y'all do
appreciate it man take it easy see ya
that was fun man yeah that was great he
was he was fantastic i had a
what a great guest yeah he was great man
so make sure you guys support him yeah
make sure you uh keep up with him so
that uh
when he inevitably gets nuked from
youtube it's in a half somewhere else